la main humaine est le résultat de
millions d'années d'évolution sa
dextérité et d'une finesse remarquable
la pratique du piano en est un bon
exemple
mais c'est une tâche exigeante un
chercheur de l'université de montréal
temps de réduire le risque de blessures
chez les pianistes
[Musique]
la mélodie est douce et enveloppante
mais derrière la pureté et la grâce il
ya des heures de dur labeur
[Musique]
des gestes précis répété sans relâche
pour atteindre la perfection
les pianistes se fatiguent et se blesse
aussi souvent
c'est quelque chose qui est reconnu
comme étant faible intensité
mais elle à répéter constamment
constamment constamment dans que ça
devient une activité assez intense
felipe verdugo à étudier et enseigne
aujourd'hui le piano à l'université de
montréal
là on commence à l'entendre mieux je
pense la proche de sa faculté prom non
seulement la maîtrise des gestes des
mains et des bras pour interpréter la
musique mais aussi celle du centre du
corps en fait ces mouvements là qu on le
fait on le fait pour la main droite une
méthode relativement atypique dans le
milieu et peu documentée mais qui
pourrait aider à optimiser la pratique
du piano et réduire le risque de
blessures chez les interprètes
quand
pour le vérifier le pianiste a troqué la
salle de concert pour le laboratoire le
musicien s'est fait biomécanicien
son équipe nous accueille dans ce labo
du département de kinésiologie
ici l'instrument de musique devient un
instrument de recherche
il va permettre de décortiqué dans les
moindres détails les gestes des
pianistes
[Musique]
justine pelletier est affublé d'une
série de capteurs qui vont suivre ses
mouvements aux claviers
les capteurs orageux permettre de capter
le mouvement de la femme du corps qui
ont les a placés à peu près dans les
parties du corps pour voir les
mouvements de l'ensemble du corps sauf
dans les doigts ou là on va justement
placé des marqueurs réfléchissant qui
vont être justement vu par les caméras
entre ruche qui sont placées autour du
piano
sur l'écran un logiciel recréer les
gestes de la musicienne
on
son avant-bras forcément est l'objet de
beaucoup d'attention il est couvert de
petites électrodes
c'est sûr qu'au piano c'est là où on va
la trouver une activité qui est vraiment
plus importante dans ce qu'elle apprécie
les électrodes nous permette vraiment
d'avoir l'activité de l'ensemble des
muscles qui contrôle les doigts et le
poignet donc le capter juste d'un but
précis on va vraiment aller chercher une
activité générale pendant jeu ce qui
nous permet vraiment une idée plus
précise de ce qui se passe quand on joue
au piano
mais les chercheurs s'intéressent aussi
au centre du corps en particulier au
bassin et au thorax
quand on étudie d'un point de vue
mécanique les jeux pianistique mais il
faut prendre en compte ses articulations
mans également parce qu'ils font partie
et la chaîne cinématique qui va avoir un
impact sur les mouvements des doigts de
la main skip a fait presque jamais dans
le domaine et c'est vraiment ça qui on
voulait étudier de notre côté parce que
d'abord c'est ça qui est ici dans la
proche à la fois goûté musique mais
aussi sait pas ce que c'est c'est
pour nous c'était très important de
montrer que la chanson toute la chaîne
du pianiste elle commence vraiment du
sens du coroner pas seulement
les données révèlent qu effectivement la
rotation du bassin peut contribuer à
augmenter de 35% la vitesse transmises
vers l'avant du bras pour enfoncer les
touches
dans la suite du mouvement pour relâcher
rapidement les touches le pianiste peut
utiliser son thorax son redressement
contribue alors à la vitesse verticale
les bras
il ya ces 15 des mouvements dans
l'hérault les différents foyers à
certains moments qui vont avoir un rôle
pour l'attack d'autres mouvements qui
ont lieu presque en même temps vont
avoir un rôle pour le relâchement de la
touche c'est ce qu'on voit du point de
vue de l'organisation des mouvements
dans notre but ce qui indiquerait donc
été les peines peuvent profiter de citer
cette stratégie là en incluant ceux de
la chan
dans une seconde étude philippe et
verdugo et son équipe ont voulu vérifier
quels mouvements dans la technique
pianistique sont plus susceptibles de
causer de la fatigue et des blessures
pour le savoir une cinquantaine
d'interprètes se sont éreintés au piano
ils ont répété en boucle un extrait
d'une pièce rapide et d'une autre fait
d'accord puissant ou fil de cette
exigeante exercice les pianistes
évaluent leur niveau de fatigue padduc
sur leur avant bras droit le plus
sollicité par le répertoire les
électrodes mesure l'activité musculaire
[Musique]
on n'avait pas une référence pour voir
hockey pendant quinze jours longtemps
comment la fatigue évolué chez les
pièces et particulièrement de la fatigue
dans des muscles à fonder des doigts et
des poignets qui se retrouvent dans
l'avant bras et qui sont ceux qui sont
plus à risque de blessure la pratique en
soins telle
conclusion certains pianistes se
fatiguent beaucoup plus vite que
d'autres
et leurs muscles ne se fatigue pas non
plus de manière égale
lorsqu'on joue du piano pour faire
descendre la touche on pense souvent aux
muscles fléchisseurs d'encaisser qui
sont responsables de la descente de la
touche d'un qui est de faire descendre
les doigts finalement alors c'est pas
eux qui se fatiguent le plus ceux qui
sont responsables du relâchement de la
touche ou de la stabilisation des
articulations dollar
un indice qui pourrait aider les experts
à proposer des mouvements qui réduirait
la pression sur ses articulations
c'est très intéressant parce que ça veut
dire que les stratégies que les
pianistes peuvent développer pour
réduire le risque de blessure doivent
pas être forcément pensé tout le temps
pour rendre plus efficaces les attaques
de la touche mais surtout également au
moins pour rendre plus efficaces les
relâchements de la touche
mais si des gestes plus efficaces ou +5
peuvent être validés d'un point de vue
biomécanique ils ne deviendront pas
nécessairement une recette miracle pour
les musiciens
on
on est toujours dans une dualité où on
veut réduire le reste des lieux sûrs
mais aussi on veut optimiser la
performance d'elle même ce serait donc
des recommandations qui visent ces deux
objectifs à la fois ils trouveront sur
des compromis entre les lieux pour pour
qu'elle soit vraiment utile pour le
pianiste parce que si on développe des
mouvements qui sont sains mais qui
finalement ne nous empêche en fait
finalement des d'attendre certains du
musicaux mais finalement c'est un
mouvement qui même s'ils sont très
simples mais ils sont pas utiles en fait
preuve qu'ils ont fait hier lorsqu'on
est sur la scène
à chaque pianiste de s'approprier ces
techniques pour que toute la puissance
de son corps jouent à l'unisson ou
services de la partition